the question I get a lot is how do you
bridge the gap between two completely
different whys inside an organization
it's a good question it's especially
when you feel like you're working at
cross-purposes now if it's done properly
the Y should be nested within something
higher so for example the United States
has a why it's based on the Declaration
of Independence all men are created
equal right now within the United States
we have nested Y's each state has a Y
each city has its own Y in other words
Los Angeles has a very different Y from
New York some people belong in New York
some people belong in Los Angeles they
are not the same but they're both
distinctly American they belong in
America Los Angeles wouldn't make sense
in France just wouldn't make sense so
it's gonna be the same inside an
organization operations may seem to have
a completely different way than
marketing for example just like Los
Angeles of New York you need to belong
here or you belong there but they should
both feel like they fit in the
overarching why and that's actually how
you find common ground so when you feel
like you're working at cross-purposes
the opportunity is to actually take it
up a level in other words you say hey
remember the why of this organization
remember why this organization exists
and we're both serving to advance that
cause so that means we're working
together we are cooperative so whenever
you find that you're at each other
because you have different why's or if
you feel like they're competing try and
re articulate that competition as two
cooperative we're cooperating together
serving different ways in order to
advance the greater good and that's how
you find cooperation with seeming
competitive wise inside the same
organization